- Fun in life.
If you don't have no fun in
life, ain't nothing happening.
(metal creaking)
- Hi Stephanie, I'm Avalon.
Nice to meet you.
- Hello, nice to meet you Avalon.
- My name is Roland.
- Good to meet you.
- I'm 22 years old, it's
my last year in college.
I'm just trying to figure
out what's next, I guess.
- You're a senior in high school?
Do you know what your major is?
- Probably international affairs.
- How did you go about choosing that?
- Well that's what I love.
- You're at a point now where
the world is your oyster.
You must stay positive.
It's your call.
- I thought I wanted to be a nurse
because I wanted to help people.
And I found out that it
was not good fit for me
and so, I wasted like
two years and some money.
- I'm still learning so much about myself.
There's so many things that I like,
and so it's just like, it's
hard to narrow it down.
- What do you like?
- I love fashion.
- Well you're dressed up
nice, I love your outfit.
That jacket is on the move.
- Thanks.
- You could be excellent at that.
Interviewing people about fashion.
Keep your mind open,
create your own space.
- In high school, I had
enjoyed taking my typing class
and I liked being organized.
My friend suggested how about clerical,
how about going into secretarial?
So I went back to
college, changed my major,
learned that, and I had many happy years
as an administrative assistant.
Also I advise young
people to talk to people
who know them really well,
whether it's a best friend,
a boyfriend or girlfriend,
and they'll probably
have a very good insight.
- I was the only black person
an all-white football team
and I was the quarterback and the captain.
So I took that discipline
of all of that stuff with me
to UCLA and had a great time.
But I made my own rules.
- And you can count all of
the black people at our school
and I was one of them
and it was just like,
and on top of me being like
gay and being openly gay
and androgynous, like, you
know, it was like definitely--
- It's a challenge.
- It was a lot of
challenge but I liked it.
- Intellectually,
spiritually, and passionately,
you were above it all.
That's how you were able to pull it off.
- So love, I mean, I'm
about that age where
I should be starting to look
for my partner in crime.
- I met my husband in college.
I just liked so much about him.
Of course, the big test
was to meet the family.
- I'm the only girl in the family so
every single person's
gonna be so protective.
- Very protective.
- I feel bad for whoever I pick.
Oh geez.
- But I think when it's the right fit,
he'll fit right in and
they'll love him like a son.
- They always say, like
you know, you, I guess,
like you want what you can't have.
I guess that goes along
those lines because
I feel like I've through that too.
But I was always after the
one that was just not really,
I mean, that's just my experience.
You know, I'm after the one--
- You always want what you can't have.
- Yeah, that was just like kind
of like, not texting me back
as much and just being like
whatever, you know, short
and because it was just
more of a, it was like more
intriguing.
- That's always a learning experience.
Why do I want that?
Why can't I get it?
What's the best for me?
Sometimes you have to just let it slide.
As my old grandmother
used to say, do without
and keep on moving.
You know, I have just such
a broad spectrum of friends
and we're very open with one another.
Be that way.
Stay open.
Keep the lines of communication open.
Always make known your feelings
so there is no confusion.
- Having raised four sons, we
never had a lot of extra cash.
But we always look for
opportunities to have fun.
Watching the sunrise over the mountain
or the sunset over the ocean.
A kiss, a hug, a smile.
There's a lot of beauty
to be found in life.
And it doesn't cost a penny.
The worst regrets that
I've heard is people saying
that they were too busy chasing success
or being selfish with their time.
That they didn't spend time or
take time for their families.
- You make me want to call my parents.
- That's good.